a better guy a better guy yeah I'm gonna
give you two options me or what's the
the big guy that I know there's so many
glasses black Eric Eric Griffin Griffin
with Griffin
Dolly baby what stop us yeah who's a
better guy yeah Bobby Lee or Eric
Griffin on air right now right now let's
go
history with Eric go to the pros and
cons right now I'm I don't have any
history with Jesus Christ but he's a
better guy I agree yes thank you
[Laughter]
um I mean I'll go I'll I'll go with Eric
okay good yeah uh who's a better guy me
or Adam DeVine Adam okay who's the
better guy me you me or the other guy I
don't know the other guy's name Andres
yeah Anders
Andre is for sure it's a weird test yeah
this feels real bad I mean I I believe
we could our friendship could grow we
could be friends
I'm not working with a lot other than
like a dinner eight years ago where he
wouldn't look me in the eyes
yeah
like Ellen does but my point is is that
I am the Asian Ellen yeah you are I've
always said that about you okay I know
but can I say let me defend I wanted to
tell you that that night but you
wouldn't let me talk
all right let me defend Ellen then yeah
okay okay right I'm gonna defend Ellen
right okay she you could obviously tell
she's not in a good place in her heart
okay when you treat people like that
right yes there's something going on
with her right and she's um
self-centered and she's you know
probably not in therapy and not working
on herself and she's in a lot of pain
right so why can't we you know and I
already apologize
I said I was in a lot of pain I admitted
my frailties and and you know my
wrongdoings I you did admit I made
amends but you still have to be punished
I lost a movie I know that was your
punishment and I had you on my podcast
well this is this is big of you yeah
this is my this is my immense tool yeah
retribution right yeah who else was that
was that other guy Jesus excuse me was
the other guy I did or two the guy the
guy from Workaholics Adam was
I know Adam the other one oh Anders no
oh what's his name Anders Andre he
wasn't there there's was not there he
has no history with me none right yeah
and then did I treat Adam DeVine like
[__] no you were treating him okay
because I think Adam had been like on
some shows and so coming okay
sorry we have to we have to get past
this
we passed it I'm not yeah it sounds a
little bit like you
back then what the [__] are you doing
right now wait you said eight years ago
it might have even been more it had to
be yeah I want to say it could have been
10 to 12. oh yeah so 12 years ago it was
before me premium so before you yeah
right so you're right now how what was I
like back then you're doing it again
what like we have a guest on and you are
not getting to know him this whole thing
has been about your mistake okay listen
but let's talk for a second yeah
this is weird
[Laughter]
right yeah and you know what I did that
with my mind
yeah it's a scare tactic yeah yeah so
oh it's fine yeah that's fine all right
now it's double dead
oh that's a [__] um
from uh yeah what they call those or
June something yeah
um yeah wow you know that